I really hate the fact that this is even
a public story hey let's let's
why you airing this [__] out to the
whole world on social media this is the
thing I hate about this generation who
cares she left yeah you know what's
funny though what he has a fiance she
just gave birth this comes out right
afterwards
Jonah Hill is getting canceled right now
by his ex-girlfriend for allegedly being
misogynistic and narcissistic she took
the following private conversation via
text messages to her Instagram story
last night with Jonah Hill says speaking
out is so important though basically
she's a surfer
yeah okay and he was uncomfortable with
the fact that she had pictures of her in
bathing suits or surfing he was
uncomfortable that she was with other
men she now comes out saying this is all
manipulation whatever whatever you get
what I'm saying narcissist all the other
person yeah also I'll put the text on
screen so you guys can read it because
I'm not going to do a play-by-play for
like 10 different stories if you want to
read it that badly you can read it there
but I'm not going to read through all
the texts I'm giving you guys the gist
of it because that's really what it is
this is from a therapist okay
Tick Tock therapist Jonah Hill was using
therapy speak to control his girlfriend
Sarah his now ex-girlfriend and it's
important that we go over this misuse of
therapy language which is kind of a
thing these days and how it can be super
problematic as it masks controlling
Behavior under a commonly accepted
positive Concept in this case boundaries
making it harder for the person on the
receiving end Sarah to challenge it okay
so Jonah is basically telling his
professional Surfer girlfriend I am not
going to be with you if you surf with
men have boundaryless friendships with
men model post pictures in a bathing
suit or post suggestive pictures and are
friends with women who are in unstable
places he goes on to say that these are
my boundaries for a romantic
relationship Jonah's use of the term
boundaries in this message is a misuse
of the concept A boundary is a healthy
limit a person sets for themselves to
protect their well-being and integrity
it is a rule or guideline that one
creates to identify a reasonable all
safe and permissible ways for others to
behave towards them and how they'll
respond when someone passes those limits
however and the message Jonah sent to
Sarah he is not setting boundaries that
protect his emotional well-being instead
he is dictating what behaviors and
friendships Sarah is permitted to have
he's essentially instructing Sarah on
who she can be friends with what she can
do professionally and how she can show
up online this is not an example of
healthy boundary setting instead it
reflects an attempt at control it
demonstrates a lack of respect for
Sarah's autonomy and individuality a
boundary doesn't just have to be about
yourself it can be about your
relationship it can be about your kids
it can be even about your property it
can be about a different things you guys
are not calling the boundary if you guys
are seeing somebody you're in a
relationship and you find out your
partner still having constant
conversations about with their ex about
your current relationship
a lot of people gonna feel uncomfortable
with that and you say I'm not down with
that that's a boundary it's okay to say
that people talk about autonomy autonomy
this is where like this feminist lingo
goes a bit full [__] when you get in a
relationship guess what there are
certain things you just can't do anymore
what those things are will depend on how
you negotiate that with your partner
right
but there's gonna be certain things you
can't do no more so what was the list
here surfing with men okay so she's a
surfer he doesn't feel comfortable
surfing man on most cases I would say
like why is that a battery you would be
settings but I also don't know the
context of the relationship has she
slept with a bunch of these guys
has she been sending flirty messages
really going back and forth in the past
right people flirt with a lot of people
that they work with or do something with
I don't know I'm not saying that's it's
what happened what I'm saying is we
don't know what the with the confines of
the dynamic is like
um Bounder boundary less inappropriate
friendships with men why is he saying
that maybe those men are sending
messages that are completely
inappropriate to somebody in a
relationship you should be able to have
male friends but if they're sending
messages to you like that to you can you
not understand why a partner might feel
some type of way or maybe the opposite
is true maybe she's had these friends
since childhood there's never been
anything weird and Jonah's just mad
insecure
I don't know
but neither do any of you at home
nobody knows that's the reality Jonah's
message is more about restricting
Sarah's Behavior to suit his comfort
levels and insecurities rather than
expressing his feelings or needs in a
healthy manner a healthier fear and less
manipulative approach might be for Jonah
to express how Sarah's actions make him
feel without using ultimatums about what
she should or should not do
how do you know that conversation didn't
happen
apparently these people have been going
to therapy how do you know it just
started with an ultimatum
how do you know this is born from
insecurity not from the fact that Sarah
can be flagrantly inappropriate I'm not
saying it's unsecure but how do you know
how does anybody know that's why I'm
confused when this whole thing [__]
unfolded because I'm like I don't know
these people y'all don't know these
people so why is everybody being a
Tick-Tock detective like they've been
sniffing Blue's Clues and got all the
answers I think you did a pretty good
job my boundaries are this I I don't
like that I don't like that I don't like
that I don't like that isn't that what
we wanted people to express themselves
people to be able to just say what they
want not keep that inside not bottle up
that's what he did
now Sarah has a choice to stay or to get
that's it
yeah but they're probably gonna say that
ultimatums are manipulative or
controlling
sure
and I don't think it's a bad thing you
know what yes you're right but it's not
inherently bad it's not inherently bad
because at some point if you keep
[__] up someone's gonna get and then
it's okay yeah as a matter of fact I'm
could be like hey you know what if you
keep doing this [__] imma get imma leave
that's an ultimatum and that's an
ultimatum and I think I think an
ultimatum is valid if you get in a
relationship and then you keep your your
online account of Tinder or whatever
open that someone might give you an
ultimatum to shut that [__] down and I
think it's valid an ultimatum is valid
all right listen you first you might
listen you don't lead with an ultimatum
you always have a conversation very
civilly and say like why is this there
let's have a conversation but if they
just keep
you know I mean flagrantly disrespecting
the the nature of the relationship thing
yeah that's okay to say not going too
far
again I'm not saying this guy is
insecure or is not or she is
inappropriate I don't know so why does
everyone else like hold up maybe people
are privy to [__] I don't know about so
if that's the case I need to see that
[__] people are calling him an abuser
okay okay I'm gonna say be honest with
y'all this word getting used really
liberally very very liberally
and I'm starting to look at people being
like okay when you say views what do you
mean
I I you have to now there's a lot of
people who just say oh my God
he verbally abused me why because he was
a shitty boyfriend who cares stop do I
like what he was saying that stuff me
personally I think is corny when
somebody meets somebody in a profession
and then tries to date them and make
them change how would they do everything
that's stupid to me the girl has like
hundreds of pictures of her surfing in
regular normal bathing suits and now
that's usually with you you want to have
her change her whole wardrobe in her
whole lifestyle as a matter of fact
that's probably how you she got your eye
he was like oh
oh
and then you saw her in them pictures
and you was like oh drop in the DMS and
then whenever you're in a relationship
you're like you don't do that no more
you're the one who's acting brand new
yeah I'm saying like she was acting like
that before if I meet a partner they
know I dance then they come in my life
they'd be like I don't want you days
with other women I'll be like you take a
hike you're not gonna tell me what I'm
not gonna do anymore but my someone I
love my whole life
it's not like I'm out here grinding all
women grabbing ass or grabbing titties
and doing things that's incredibly
sexual not not a hobbyist stripper I'm
not a hobbyist escort even I have a
passion even if you were if you were
before yeah and I get in the
relationship and you were before yo what
you got in that relationship knowing
that what it was hey like I'm not saying
that she's doing wrong or bad I don't
care about that what I'm saying is if
you're getting in a relationship with
someone that was a certain way before
you know us man we don't like whenever
like a girl gonna come in a relationship
and be like trying to change this no I'm
gonna change him we always talk about
these women saying that [__] right
um I'm gonna change him I'm doing that
and we think that [__] is corny we think
a woman going in a relationship trying
to save a dude is corny you met him like
that you're not gonna change nobody
you're not gonna change nobody the
person's gonna decide to change whenever
the person's gonna decide to change we
always say that we always say that I
know I say that a lot and I agree with
that because women done that and not
stay saying that we're not going to
change a man in the relationship you're
not that person I mean I'm gonna
actually you're not he's going to change
if he wants he wants to change to be
fair I've seen some men change
it was
or they wanted to change that's still a
decision that they made you understand
what I'm saying now [__] no I'm not
saying that she is a good thing that you
change the bad thing that you change I
don't care you're not gonna change the
[__] we always clown woman and
we always own the woman's back whenever
they trying to change man
flip side that's what happened yeah dude
got arrested now yeah you see that
there's a possibility that I also men do
that thing that behavior that's why I
don't really sometimes I don't believe
in these women or these men is people
because you can see these traits in old
people yup okay so now you see this dude
I'm not gonna hurt at least I can say
that he's an abuser we're going on tour
we come into cities near you we want to
see you [__] face to face where
you at we gonna be doing shows awesome
well this summer we're doing three shows
we're doing Detroit Pittsburgh and
Washington DC but afterwards we were
going to England we're going to be going
all across America Asia so if you want
to get tickets make sure you guys go to
the website all right put your name so
we can email you as soon as those
tickets come out for your area we won't
bombard you with nothing else okay I
promise yeah
um we want to see you guys at the shows
we meet us we have meet and greets we're
gonna have a lot of fun we're gonna be
laughing so it's gonna be a good time uh
but we want to see you guys I'm not
gonna go as far as that I don't have
enough evidence to say abuser that's a
bit far-fetched that's a bit much I
don't know hold up let me ask you a
question go ahead do you ever think they
would say a woman is in a quote-unquote
abuser when she trying to change a man's
clothes no trying to change a man's
lifestyle try to change the way he does
everything okay I just want to
appreciate this word as a heavy
connotation for generally only being
veered towards you know I bet he loved
how hot Sarah looked in her posts before
they got together so this is a bunch of
[__] anyway Jonah needs to consider
Sarah's needs and feelings and not just
focus on his own which it seems like
he's selfishly even if he hasn't and she
leaves that's that true and there's
going to be someone that's going to be
okay with the confound that relationship
in that but she wasn't so she got who
cares she left yeah you know what's
funny though what she has a fiance she
just gave birth this comes out right
afterwards
what the [__] wait so he has a brand new
thing fiance and this comes now they
just gave birth and this comes now
bitter [__]
why are we talking about this because
she felt like she needed to speak her
mind
she claims she claims she waited till
after the pregnancy because she didn't
want to put stress on the mother while
she was no that's us
I really hate the fact that this is even
a public story hey let's let's
make more there
okay you had a boyfriend he wasn't that
great why are you airing this [__] out
to the whole world on social media this
is the thing I hate about this
generation that's why at least if you
talk about it anonymously I kill respect
it sounds because you're just talking
about your experience without [__]
putting a whole social media thing on it
but you had to be vindictive and a
little [__] about it and make a whole
public story because he wasn't that
great of a boyfriend that's what it
really came down to he didn't tell you
hold hostage he didn't threaten you with
violence he didn't say you're a dump he
didn't say none of that he said listen
these are my boundaries or maybe you can
think they're unreasonable whatever but
to air it out I think is what is the
worst thing because now you're just
bring a media storm on somebody just
because they're worth their best
boyfriend to you keep it pushing I could
pull any of you [__]
relationship conversations and I promise
you if I isolated those texts and got
your significant other to say that
shit's manipulative on social media you
would look like a piece of [__]
absolutely absolutely every text message
conversation you take little Snippets
like this right there and there I can
make anybody look like unless the
conversation we murdering or something
crazy yo any body could look crazy but
anyways I think that's most of my
thoughts on this whole matter I don't
think it needs to go any longer anything
you want to say this comes out right
after the Keke Palmer thing when I'm
like why is Chipotle you
you have to put that [__] public God
though y'all messy for me he likes to
put that [__] yeah yeah this is actually
something we gotta fight against more
and more we start need to start shaming
people for making things public that
have no business being public I think
that's what we need to normalize doing
one last thing Jonah Hill made a lovely
documentary about therapy and it's a
shame to see him weaponizing what he
learned to attempt to manipulate his
girlfriend that sucks
John it's actually kind of [__]
disgusting that you got therapists up
here just yipping and yapping like their
opinions are really solid on this matter
when it's just like you could Google
these definitions this guy's just making
[__] up
and that's what shows you that's why you
need to go see Kent therapists before
you find the right one because a lot of
these people are just [__] quacks
they're just quacks and you can see it
right here
honestly I'm all for people going to
therapy and getting mental health but
honestly this whole mental health age I
really hate it I hate the lingo I hate
the people who use it all the time I
hate the way therapists be up online
just saying a bunch of random [__]
unsubstantiated opinions and they use
their Authority as a professional as if
it's solid just get the [__] out of here
any means you want to say no I really
thought it was something right this
whole thing is actually kind of sick
yeah I'm seeing all kinds of stupid
[__] posts from people being like Oh
my God autonomy what uh
maybe I just don't understand what it
means to be in a relationship anymore
look at this one look at this one
demanding control over your partner's
autonomy is not having boundaries
suck this [__] off
can I just ask is it ever acceptable to
say in a relationship I'm not okay with
my partner doing certain things I'm not
okay my partner talking to X's I'm not
okay my partner flirt with people I'm
not okay with my partner is that ever
okay
but anyways
that's all
let's just